go on on the uh the the united states i  i just want to and and the election i  want to say  that all my life america has stood for  some very important things  an idea of freedom and an idea of  democracy and  uh as you as you say as you suggest in  so far as  uh he encouraged people to  uh storm the the capital and in so far  as the  uh the president consistently has cast  doubt on  uh the outcome of a free and fair  election i i believe that that was  completely wrong i think what president  trump has uh been saying about that has  been  uh completely wrong and i  people understand behave in the  disgraceful way  that they did in the capital and all i  can say is i'm  very pleased that the president-elect  has now been  uh properly confed duly confirmed  in office and that democracy has  prevailed